Một bà trái gì vậy?
Trái gì vậy?
Cháy, cháy, cháy, cháy, cháy, cháy, cháy, cháy, cháy, cháy, cháy, cháy, cháy, cháy, cháy, cháy.
Không có lâu như mà nó còn bui nữa là thích.
Quên cháy nhá, như thế nào nó có lâu luôn.
Cái sao gây, như thế nữa, Vé.
Đó là hay một hạn con xem ở đâu.
Thầy là một sự kỹ đôi, nó có...
Cháy, cháy đứt.
Em biết là buồn hán hút thì mà chống bị được đi con sách tờ...
Cô dẹ.
Em đi cùng 2 bản đúng không?
Múng là 3 đứa có thể đúng cùng chung mục cái zong
Hãy cảm xúc quay mơ khi nhận được
Lâm phải tổ chung tìm
Em đứa có vui tại vì là em là chung nhận được
Tăng kính mà em có được vẻ
Bây giờ là em chỉ mộm muốn là hẳn phút thôi
Em đột vài đọc lập là tua đả rời
Nên 2 đứa xuyên của 1 mũ
Cháy được quay chỗ như tất cả người thà
Và không khuy cũng hẹn gói chung xác
Vũi kia tổ chung tìm
Là mà bạn có tầm đi ăn
Nó mùi rồi mà là nếu là tao giữ cái ngày mà
Tổ chung trở lại cái ngày giễn chinh em cũng đi
Trời là cẩu gì mình đi còn xói kia vào ngày
Hát tối đây, cái bây giờ còn 1 mũ lửa xói chung hả chung hả chung hả?
Cẩu xong tìm là
Mọi người đều tọng lòng hạm lại.
Chúng mục bài và lại em rưỡa phức trời hữu vật sự quân với nửa bình.
Nó là em mới muốn phang đêm đi được ký tối trọng tìm.